tout ce qu'on voit là
ces bonbons floraux donc on voit bien
qu'il y en a pas mal qui ont cramé la
dent que j'ai malgré le ciel bleu et le
soleil présent les températures de
certaines nuit d'avril ont été négatives
comme celles de samedi 9 et dimanche 10
avril une conséquence directe sur les
productions agricoles ici à feucherolles
leslie elle faire cultive des kiwis en
bio elle a planté deux hectares en 2018
et attend une première récolte fin
octobre l'arboriculteur est inquiète du
gel sur ces cultures et trois nuits de
gel la dernière était la plus forte donc
donc voilà on a les deux premières mais
on avait réussi à les sauver à -2 ça
avait tenus au moins trois 3 7 sympa je
pense qu'il ya 70% des bourgeons qui ont
joué cette nuit pareil il est annoncé -
un sous abri ce qui veut dire que quand
c'est pas sous abri c'est au moins deux
voire moins trois des techniques sont
donc utilisés pour réduire les dégâts
comme l'aspersion des jets d'eau qui
arrosent les cultures en continu leslie
elle faire utilise une autre solution
elle fait brûler de la paille tout
autour du verger il faut l'éviter c'est
énorme ballots de paille qui font 4 500
kg pour faire des espèces de cordon
assez épais tout au long tout autour du
verger dans les parties centrales
qu'on va humidifiés sinon ça brûle
beaucoup trop vite le but c'est quand
même de
que ça chauffe environs de 2 ou 3 heures
du matin jusqu'à ce que le soleil
chauffe sur la parcelle on arrive
probablement à gagner à un bon degré
qui est stratégique l'état a mis en
place le régime des calamités agricoles
il assure aux exploitants touchés par un
sinistre climatique caractérisé comme
exceptionnel une indemnisation partielle
de leurs pertes ouais j'ai reçu une
compensation financière mais c'est alors
c'est très bien parce que effectivement
ça permet quand même l'aider et
d'absorber quelques coups mais
malheureusement ça remplace pas du tout
une récolte en fait si on est soumis à
ce genre de contraintes année après
année
faire du curatif ça mais n'est pas une
sera vide à pour personne ni pour l'état
ni pour nous donc il va falloir trouver
des moyens en amont de lutter contre
tout ça en attendant des épisodes de gel
sont possibles jusqu'au 15 mai période
et sans glace